okay so we can start like slow and see
if more people join my name is Santiago
I work we have a company that we do
online courses data science by the
government courses since the beginning
we were interested in kind of creating
this bridge between the two like two big
aspects of Python right data science and
web development and actually when we
started the big micro-services slash
land this world was starting to catch a
little bit of fire we try it and it's
been great since uh since that time and
to now it like during these cup like
these final year I'd say what if I can
increase the size yes wait
don't change
I can change the resolution very good
that's got you better to watch okay
and as I was saying when we have so we
have for example a group of people
coming from data world and we show them
what they can build with these kind of
web technologies they are not web
technologies is a combination of web
plus cloud and they are usually
impressed right because it's extremely
simple to get started and to like give
your own data processing like internal
framework the capabilities of cloud so
the idea of today is just show you a
live example of how to work with lambdas
how to get your own API deployed the
name was API but I started transforming
the talk to give like other aspects of
it so we're gonna do multiple things and
there are actual things will be left out
because we will not have time but I have
steel pointing in now in case you want
to check them on your own so I don't
know if you're familiar with the idea of
micro-services slash AWS landis every
cloud provider will have this idea for
lambda or a cloud function that it's
just a way for you to package your code
upload it somewhere and you can execute
it without the need of maintaining the
infrastructure right so think about a
simple task that runs every day of 9:00
a.m. in the morning pulls data does some
certain transformation and stores it in
I don't know s3 on a database somewhere
so if you think about the problematic
right there it's extremely simple to do
right just pull the data from whatever
it is it's a sequel query do the
transformation you guys know how to do
and that's it the complication is like
you start to get frustrated when you
sort
thinking how am I going to deploy this
am I going to create an ec2 instance and
I am I going to use a virtual server
that I have how am I gonna write a cron
job how can I store monitoring it right
should I log in every day at 10 a.m. and
run the the logs to see if the current
fail or not etc so that's the the
problem with it so that's area I'm
trying to scroll back so you guys can
see this project so that's the idea of
AWS Landis actually I should open the
lam this website um it's lawless
as everything Amazon does it's kind of
like these self-contained project within
or product within Amazon right that you
can start using unwanted kind of started
is that like a really promising feature
but it was kind of useless because you
could you have to manually have to
literally zip your code and use an
upload button to upload I don't know 50
megabyte package to lambda and then it
sits there right and the idea of a
lambda is that it's always responding to
event okay it's always responding to
events different types of events so an
image is uploaded to an s3 bucket or in
s3 location and you can react to that
event and for example resize it that was
kind of the promise of lens when inside
an event can also be a user pointing
something to an API right just
requesting something to an API but again
when it came when he came out it's like
he was really promising but it was
really hard to get started because he
had to use multiple services to get
something running you had to create the
lambda manually uploading the package
you had to test it in some other
environment then you had to configure
something that Amazon calls gateway and
then you had to manage Logs with another
Amazon product it was like this big
mixture of products you had to all put
together
with the console and it was extremely
painful so that's why people started
building these kind of services Zappa is
the one we're gonna use today the one we
use more often there is another one
official from AWS which is chalice and
there are a couple of ones probably the
most popular one in the node.js last
JavaScript environment which is
serverless right this was one of the
first ones and again the idea is that
it's gonna help you orchestrate your app
so you can just write a couple of files
run some commands and get something
running pretty much immediately and this
involves pretty much everything you can
respond like you can set the
configuration of a given event or
timeout on the day so the same
application we were mentioning you can
create kind of a configuration file say
every day at 9:00 a.m. run this thing
upload it to s3 then you set another
lamb that catches that s3 upload and
process it and stores it for example in
I don't know DynamoDB then you can set
an event for that dynamodb and that's
when we start thinking about micro
services it's not just one gigantic
function that does everything at once
but it's like the combination of smaller
components all being kind of chained by
the events something really good about
lambdas - I was just thinking about it
and trying to add it but it didn't have
enough time is the cost of it is
extremely cheap alright it's extremely
cheap to run lambdas we run several
production Landers and our cost is below
$1 with like hundreds of thousands of
requests per month it's incredibly cheap
I don't know how if the way is it's it
gets charged is basically by the amount
of time your code is running so if you
have a really an optimized function it's
going to be more
offensive compared to the two one that
is a little bit more optimized it's a
Trojan horse yeah so let's get started
the idea is again to show you a real
example so by the way this is one
service we're running it's kind of a
it's called
remoter czar company we're opening for
everybody in the education space like a
my buying they're kind of project so you
can run your own notebooks it's
completely free and open you guys can
use it if you want it's again targeted
for education so and what we're gonna be
doing is we want to write a simple
website that we will be transforming
into an API and then we're gonna do some
scheduling as I told you with that to
process data about different
cryptocurrencies so we're gonna use the
service which is crypto watch I don't
know if you've ever used it that gives
you free data about multiple
cryptocurrencies on markets right so uh
there's a I get summary all these
markets and pairs are available so for
example I don't know you can use okay
coin and get Paris for example Bitcoin
with a client of their futures there
it's a it's a pretty open API so
we start this thing
so basically what I've built here and
you guys can by the way if you go to the
east page that I'm gonna share later you
can fork this entire project and you can
run it on your own later so basically
what we're doing is we're pulling
historical prices of a given
cryptocurrency on a given market that
will not be important and in this case
gives you this data frame right so we
have just a couple of prices and we can
plot right to add a little bit of
something a little bit more interesting
we're gonna be applying to it some
Bollinger Bands so we can pretty much
write do some technical analysis on it
the objective at the end of this
tutorial will be to set up a one-minute
cron so every 1 minute we can check if
the current price is below or above the
land a demand so we would be trading
right I'll never do that but I just
don't use Bollinger Bands and so here's
the images we will be processing in our
website so
let me show you what we have here
there you go we'll be writing a simple
flask application - pretty much
start with it the first objective will
be to transfer the code that we have
right here right I'm sorry
right here right here that pulls the
data from the day from crypto watch the
prices and plots the Bollinger Bands and
we want to target three different
cryptocurrencies bit going like on an
ether and that will be it
I don't know if you know how flask works
but it's a micro framework it's a
relatively simple to use compared to
other Python framework frameworks and
this whole thing is served by only this
simple up we are rendering the index dot
HTML template which has the placeholders
for our charts so let's get started
which is gonna go ahead and copy the
code that's it
[Music]
so the only piece of coder that it's not
shown here is the one that it's getting
the prices it's just a request okay to
the API and there are multiple different
periods that you can ask data for crypto
watch always returns six thousand
records so depending on the periodicity
you're gonna get like more historic
prices or not right so if you ask for
minute data you're gonna get six
thousand minutes at most so that's
everything that it's hidden
I've written a simple just like reminder
here for different exchanges you guys
want to use them but that is it so with
that I can just get this thing we can do
from you daeul's
port dot
can do this and now
thing that should work
the dot
because I'm not exporting in us basics
t4 so once I get my prices I want to
well I'm missing the whole thing so
we're going to write a simple function
which is
let's fill a plot for a symbol and
exchange
right and basically we want to do
that
explored the figure and we wanted to
build these base64 code so this is
already done I will not waste your time
just doing that now so I will
check out that code we're gonna run it
again so again the first step is
completely unrelated to anything like
Sabha or blendness
or anything is just getting what we want
to do with our website Zappa will give
you by default these this this
simplicity require to get started with
flask
so the first step once you have your
data your your project working is going
to be doing the command Zappa in it by
doing this up on its gonna start our
son's asking a few questions right and
once you do it's gonna generate these
settings file actually I can just do it
so conceptually Zappa's gonna let you
work with different stages or informants
so you can have something like
production staging development etc you
can just do whatever you want
you can so what it's gonna happen is
this is kind of the whole orchestration
of AWS services that is happening behind
the scenes but it's gonna be using s3
bucket alright so that's why it's asking
about it it has it has detected that our
app right here is a flask app so it's
asking us for the entry point in this
application it's the app module and the
app name is up this is related to the
way WSGI apps work something else is
gonna happen is that with by using AWS
lenders you'll have the idea of kind of
distributing them around the world with
all the availability zones that AWS has
so you can you can have a lambda it's
deployed in multiple zones right and of
course you decrease large and once you
are done this is all we have to do this
app is going to generate this
configuration file from for from us for
us yes very good
it's the new one done so of course we
have also the process is pretty much
installing all the libraries so at some
point I did pip install and install
boquete pandas flask all the libraries
that I need plus Zappa you need to stall
Zappa because it's gonna have a bunch of
commands that it's gonna help that they
are gonna help you work with it so that
is it we have our website working I have
just initialized the app the next step
is to deploy it and it's literally Zappa
deploy we can use the stage or you can
just leave it blank because it's the
only one
what it's going to do is it's going to
create its gonna this might fail because
they have a bunch of
but it's gonna do is the way lambdas
work again is still you have to manually
upload a zip file to the cloud to their
place and that zip file is kind of
uncompressed by Amazon it has a limit on
the size it cannot exceed the 250
megabytes which is still pretty small
especially for the data science world if
you check the comments on the forums
people pushing for more size or usually
people working with for example machine
learning or data related tasks because
for us 250 megabytes extra it's small
considering the size of all these
packages that need to be usual installed
so what it's doing again it's creating a
zip file Zappa is smart enough to also
understand the so the packages you have
install I have handles for example in
step install but it's also kind of
creating a parallel of the Linux binary
that it's gonna be uploaded so it's not
pushing my package it has in this case
they are locally cached if you run this
thing for the first time it's gonna
download them but it has all these
packages that are equivalent or are
packages that work with the platform of
lambdas which is a special kind of
containerized application there is a in
the there is in my notes here you guys
can access again there is docker land
there is this project that has
environments that are pretty similar to
a real land so testing land as locally
is always complicated so you can using
docker you can kind of mimic this
environment for later just let you build
like your own lemon environment inside
so again these packages that is using
their optimized product so what it's
doing is just pushing first it pushes
the zip file to the lambda service and
start like building these
whole thing of connecting api gateway
setting up logged Sena said setting up
cloud watch for the events etc once if
your package is too large like when will
happen to me here because they have a
bunch of libraries installed in this
virtual environment what you can do is
set a sling handler would have done
right here I had this plan for later to
be honest but the idea is that what
exactly is gonna do is it's gonna upload
these new zip to s3 and the land itself
is gonna be really really small but when
it starts running it's gonna download
the package it's gonna unzip it it's
gonna start running it in memory these
might sound like a bad idea but in
reality it isn't because these lambdas
are usually kept warm there is like a
cloud which event pinging your lambda
every 4 minutes to give it warm so it
fail some reason doesn't matter I have a
couple of commands to run the first one
is about status it's gonna give you
again status of your application words
where it's deployed so right here
there you go so that is it it took me
like 10 minutes to get the website
completely deployed without worrying
about anything else
I just coded the website you guys saw it
is a pioneer in Sapa deploy and that's
it it's working with a lambda the costs
are gonna be really small and the
infrastructure like nightmare is gone
and you don't have to manage the service
right yeah
yes so there is it was an announcement a
couple of months ago it's right here on
the layers this is new this is actually
from the reinvent conference a couple of
months ago and it's the introduction of
lambda layers somewhere here these are
kind of ah the whole summary of it that
will let you push your own binaries and
create like templates so this is really
good for us because you can create your
own layer with numpy whatever you're
using and we've used the size of your
lambda this is still not supported by is
a by itself or Charlie's the other not
even Charlie's supports it this one is
the this is the SAP equivalent that I
told you is the official one from AWS
it's there if you want so this is so new
that it's not supported but yes you can
use pretty much any programming language
there is here an explanation of how to
set it up with these layers
Severus
for me it's almost the same
everything is managed by a cloud yeah
what is it
so serverless is a pretty generic term
for say I'm doing something and this
thing lives somewhere I don't know where
I don't care it's like multiple
computers there is also the serverless
framework which is a JavaScript
framework not to be confused completely
just bad choice of words
or good one if they call the domain
those are two completely different
things so this whole thing of serverless
is tied to micro services where you
think you're up again not a gigantic
monolithic app but a combination of
multiple components and you have them
all deployed differently niblet yes
separately so you can have multiple
teams working on the same I'm sorry on
multiple different projects so your app
starts growing you can have just one
thing monitoring the download of the zip
of the data every day at 9 a.m. you have
another team monitoring the processing
of it you have another team monitoring
the final you know loading of it so you
can separate in multiple components
every cloud providers gonna have cloud
function / like micro services feature
in Amazon
it's a lambda so let me show you guys
the difference between them so for
example Google Cloud functions you're
gonna see that they are pretty much the
same thing event driven several is
computing and several is computing so
these are all the same so one of the
final points that I have right here is
limitations and I mentioned that you are
kind of locked in with the vendor in
this case uh with Amazon right in
reality that is not such a pain because
the lambda itself will not be limiting
you to just one provider you can very
much switch if you are using something
like flask like numpy if you are using
open source tools etc you can just
switch to other providers like Google
Asher has its own cloud functions iBM
has IBM functions everybody has them
there are also a couple of open source
alternatives that I've mentioned right
here everybody has
of course that when you're using lambdas
you're also trying to like poking into
the whole AWS infrastructure so you can
have for example you have a lot of data
that it's creative and you're using
connexxus to kind of like a calf dive
and River event streaming service and
you plug in 2 into Connexus to listen to
events and then it's when you have the
the vendor log thing so again that is
that you are you want to deploy a
function this site that we're running
not this one this one it's running live
somewhere you guys can try accessing it
if you can copy the URL the site is just
store somewhere it's this whole project
that is packaged in a zip file lambda is
somehow pulling it I'm working with it
make sense
all right so what we've done so far is
again pretty much nothing it was like
half an hour of just working with flasks
everything else was the the deploying
part is to gust like two minutes that
buying it example deployed that's it so
you can from now that's why I call this
thing API the objective at the beginning
when I propose dog was to show you how
to bill an API and then I started
thinking like it's not so visuals it's
better to add like in better things the
second step will be we can actually turn
this thing into kind of an API just
using flask or if you want you can use
something like Django sorry Django rest
framework for example or pretty much any
other framework so what I'm gonna do now
is plug a completely different library
it's just gonna be bouquet to do pretty
much the same right so I have same code
and I want to build the same chart but
using bouquet
right on the way book it works in the
front end is by generating so you can
using Python you can generate the data
of the plot and then you can use bouquet
JavaScript side to put these two
together right so you're sending the
data on the JavaScript library try
design this is right here this is of
course dynamic right let's say you're
booking
it's gonna pull that data so let me
I will leave this thing deploying well I
expect what we'll be doing because the
deployment takes time if your connection
is not ideal so sorry one important
thing is that I generated the Zappa
thing before again so that is that you
are deploying only once and every time
that you want to update your app you run
the Saba update command and it generates
versions automatically that's also real
in it so you can always roll back right
you can as when you're creating new
versions you're not removing the
previous one you're updating and
creating one above that one so you can
always roll back this works similar to
for example Heroku or other platform as
service providers so what we're doing
right here is simple we have the same
charts as before and I'm adding a larger
one below right this is interactive and
we can pull these data right dynamically
with just a line of JavaScript to do
that what I'm doing is just fetching
kind of simulating an API call right
whenever one of these buttons are
clicked and in the up itself right here
is just pulling the data again creating
the bokeh chart on returning the JSON
document that we have so nothing new
technically it's the same it's still a
website but again it's gonna simplify if
you are building enough so usually what
we find interesting is some of our
students are working on their final
projects for example and they are really
good at what they do but they know
pretty much nothing about the web's
but they can just plug a simple API and
make it work right with a couple of
minutes this is the idea you can build a
quick API to access your announced
for your data later so steal deploying I
shoot
show you a few commands so the first one
is the one to check for logs so
everything in your example app is gonna
be locked which is really neat
especially once you have things like for
example those like schedule events that
happen every time at a given moment you
can just do a pail right and check the
logs on cloud on cloud watch right and
it's not you have to like write to a
file and SSH into the server and check
the file etc it just works there so here
here for example we have the app I'm
going to
check the starter for self it again
there you go so it's still working again
we haven't seen anything new so far it's
just about deploying the same up that we
had when you make a change remember just
Sabah update in order to update them any
questions so far make sense the idea is
I think it's it's well explained with
our first step just I have something
example deploy and I'm done I can focus
on something else
all right so our third step will be
again designing when to when we want to
operate okay so we want to whenever we
detect let me show you that graphically
so this is real data by the way so right
here we have our prize right here which
is this red cross and it's kind of above
the lower Bollinger Bands yeah it is
that whenever we detect that these
prices below the Bollinger Band we're
gonna buy whenever we decide we detect
at the bar the price is above the
Bollinger Band we're gonna sell right
that's the the really simple strategy we
have so given our whole data frame of
prices the same one right in this one I
built into the data frame the mean
standard deviation and computed the
upper and lower bands what we want to do
is decide again what to do just a simple
if statement
so what you can do with with Zampa -
it's another feature it's a feat
everything is gonna be always a feature
of AWS but um zabba is making it easier
to access it
another feature this one we want to see
now is the remote invocation feature so
you can let me point you to the right
place so you can
here so given a function you have
deployed and you can invoke it from
pretty much everywhere so you have a
legacy service right that you don't
think you should like migrate to Zappa
but you're still working on something
new so you can place these new
functionality within a lambda and
remotely invoke the function right so
you can do it that way update
what we'll be doing here is so something
important is so far the only way to
invoke a function is by providing module
/ package like the full qualified name
of the location of the function plus the
function and that by taking care of
invoking it so there are no arguments to
pass right now to these functions
although there is an unopened issue so
shouldn't take long to be implemented
the idea is that sometimes you have like
these dynamic sorry not like these ones
like these ones dynamic functions so we
have multiple symbols here that we want
to trade you can build there are a
couple of tricks where you can build
like your own module and override and
gain attribute and get it automatically
working so right now what we will be
doing is
evoking something like this but within
the lambda right and what it's going to
do is it's going to pull the whole it's
gonna build a better frame with the
upper Bann lower band and all that it's
gonna analyze the last price it's also
from the crypto watch api and then
deciding what to do in that moment so
one second so my package is all already
91 megabytes it's huge
they go
so we are gonna invoke up dot for
example trade ether
and we're gonna check the logs
there you go so master prize our van let
were been and the result of the lambda
function okay so the result of these
functions gonna be write the result of
the lambda which can be executed by
other lambda functions that's why it's
returning the result of course these
objects need to always be easy or simple
to serialize but that is just a recap
everything that you print on your land
the functions will be part of the logs
so this is extremely useful okay
you can also set environment variables
so you can write here you can change
environment variables I know if you've
ever worked with Heroku this is similar
you can also change these environment
variables within the like the front-end
of AWS or you can set them on s3 so you
can for example have a privileged pocket
right with people like all only money
and the manager has access to the pocket
and he or she can modify passwords there
and you can read them from here
so yeah just for security
make sense so far the only thing we've
done now is I've shown you the invoke
the remote invocation you can just run
coding you have in the land
so now what I want to show you is kind
of the final phase of this project where
I want to arrive again to this idea that
every minute I want to run a given
function so it's scheduling events
usually they're gonna use a cron right
in this case the only thing you do is
you create this advanced key within your
documentation
actually this is duplicate keyword so it
should be
not
this
so you set these event events key your
zaba configuration and that's it the
only thing you need to do now is
schedule
we created a radio though he creates it
they with the what
oh so so this is word yup will actually
live where the code is gonna be pushed
and it's done by Zappa automatically so
again it's great yes
ever so again creating a functioning API
slash website slash service within an
AWS lambda it's a lot of work because
there are multiple services involved in
how if you try to do this manually it's
crazy you have to upload the package you
have to set API get what you have to
store some part of the package not an s3
it's uh nightmare so the idea here is
that ends up as organs orchestrating
that and creating services for you so
here you go it's scheduled and now you
can see that it's automatically it's
running every minute performing like
these operations you can always schedule
and unscheduled that's the work so you
can just like play around with your
services with multiple frequencies right
so here the frequency rates simple just
similar it's a lot nicer than a cron job
if you're not used to a cron job so see
if this thing is still processing it I
set the final status as the return so
it's not shown here but it's still
working individual questions is
deploying the right application
CloudFormation is one application what's
the difference
so CloudFront form formation asked you
to I haven't worked with it but it asks
you to kind of build the orchestration
like the orchestration steps right
everybody's revoked at uni
you can figure out that just deploy
right from we should restore IV and it's
using easy to behind sense
I'm not sure about that this is a
template basically content paper yeah so
the I'd say I think the the difference
is that this is just relying on a lambda
instead of uh of any other like virtual
server support
in any way that your patient
[Music]
this is according to what they say they
are
this is infinitely scalable it can keep
growing you know as your app is hit on
actually what its gonna happen another
limitation that I added right here so
you don't know so for example you you
hit this page three times and you don't
know where it was served from there's no
way for you to know so maybe there were
three different computers maybe it was
all in the same one usually it's gonna
be the same one because of course there
is some certain affinity that the lemma
is keeping with the server so you can
expect that for example the crypto watch
API has a limit based on the IP address
okay so if you make multiple requests
it's usually the same API but it can
change every moment based on what Amazon
tells you it is it can keep scaling if
they notice more demand they will keep
adding servers and your lamb that will
always respond also what I told you you
can deploy to multiple availability
zones so here you can again you can set
your lambda to be deployed on every
available at its own on Amazon so Europe
Brazil here so it's like from whatever
your user is kidding right depending on
the latency they're gonna be served
first this is what they say I don't know
what's the reality to be honest we don't
have that much traffic
on to sort of wrapping it up I know how
much time we have available okay if we
have some time
the kind of the final words right there
are multiple other events to respond to
and this is usually what you should try
looking if you're interested this
depends a lot on what you're currently
working on right so you can again
respond to the fall last year but you
can respond again to an s3 upload you
can respond to a notification from SNS
you can respond to pretty much anything
so here's that the hook the whole list
we've seen chat bot that was built on
Amazon legs right and they were with an
every new response they were processing
in lambda right trying to do sentiment
analysis on the response so to see if
the client was happy or was there or not
right so you could see kind of a a chart
right then of the the current like mood
of the person who served I'd say was
like started right and not so happy and
then seems like they bought knew how to
address the issue so the response was
better etc so again all these commands
can be can be run in the last reinvent I
don't know if you had the time to say
their last reinvent conference from
Amazon personally I noticed a lot of
development on anything related to AI so
their major announcements were all
related to the AI and lambdas were
always there like a was always kind of
and panting something else that I didn't
show because I need to set up domain and
all that it takes so everything we've
done took us like five minutes I'm not
worrying about infrastructure I'm not
worrying about anything this is all
deployed in the cloud if I access my AWS
console I will see all the services that
I have so like everything was explained
and I'm trying to explain everything but
if I was creating this thing on my own
to take me like 10 minutes at most I
just do zabba deploy schedule and where
I am done if you compare that just
sending the server's SSH into it
strolling the libraries you know it's
it's a name there is also the idea of a
sync task execution so this is also
really good right so maybe the correct
way of doing it with every one minute we
detect an opportunity and we fire Anna
sank execution so let me show you here
which is just about setting a task right
decorating your function with tasks and
that's it you can then evoke it it
returns immediately but it's executed on
the background what else
oh under layers which again they are not
supported by Zappa or challenged again I
assume that it's gonna the supports
gonna be soon if you need a write of an
application that depends a lot on like
huge libraries you might want to do
layers manually of course it's not
convenient but it's there and again
their limitation we were made I was just
mentioning that you are never sure what
computer is going to serve your lambda
or fit voice already in memory or not so
that means and for example database
connection pools cannot be used right
because maybe your app is started at
that moment and there are multiple of
these old-school like paradigms right if
I start at an application today and I
know that it's gonna have a lot of
traffic the first thing that I'm gonna
do yes and as an engineering with like
ten years of experience gonna say let's
make sure the database pool is set to
the correct size because it's a no way
of thinking this way there's a little
bit more horizontal so you will not be
worrying about these things you will be
worrying about other things right but
it's usually it requires this shift in
the way you think about your apps and
then the problem becomes when you have
to organize multiple laminates because
you have either multiple github
repositories or you have multiple of
these stages right this is their
production and staging or it can be the
one trading the front-end ones it can be
like multiple stages so if you are
managing multiple microservices it gets
not so easy to manage
again both the package size and the
share libraries this is resolved by the
layers as I told you pretty much every
other cloud provider is going to have a
lambda
alternative so you can always just
switch if you need it
questions
in deciding what to do
yes exactly so that's a good question
it's all managed so all the the say plan
so all the events are gonna be managed
by cloud watch so you can always kind of
far let me see if we can see your cloud
watch event so you can even set lenders
to manage cloud watch events right so
you can always if you have a big
infrastructure of services usually what
you're gonna do is you're gonna kind of
process them a synchronous again it's
this part I'm shift what we have to do
so the first line is gonna do something
and it's gonna write an upload that
result to s3 or put a new task in a
queue right and own SQS right and you're
thinking about multiple things so if
something fails
aside from Logan what fail it's not
gonna break the rest of the app because
if you never so if they pass that we're
supposed to cue the the job doesn't do
it they are processing it will never be
run it's not gonna it's not going to
fail but that kind of again involves a
paradigm shift in the way you build a
system you can still react with a
lambda2 cloud watch events okay so you
can I think they are kind of packaged
and it's gonna send you all the events
so you can see there if you have error
so if you're logging them you could I
don't know send an email saying this
thing just fail of course you also have
regular event like error handling within
their by CUDA I could do here try it's
apt right and if I couldn't I wasn't
able to pull it I would notify someone
but I yeah events are and logs are kind
of a first-class citizen here
something else is whenever you start
doing this seriously it gets a little
bit complicated in terms of permissions
and security there's a nice way
I mean Amazon has its own way of
managing it with Virtual Private VP C's
turtle private what no I don't know it's
a V PC third yeah
cloud so it's like a subnet but software
subnet I mean it's like a circle and
then you can create subnets but
basically you can have a little bit of
Ultima City to check I'm my lambda has
permissions to access these database and
only this lambda this other lambda has
permissions to put objects in this s3
but all of these lands so you can set up
these multiple permissions right and
have more security in your earth
questions this is pretty much it
I might disappoint you if I tell you
that the real land work was like five
minutes just doing sample deploy
everything else was just explaining on
top of it but that is that is how is it
gets the purpose of flask is just to
serve the app you can use Django for
example yeah or you can just have a
regular Python up so if you're
responding to to an s3 event when a user
uploads a picture you resize it that's
that it doesn't use flash just a regular
Python function right there
[Music]
similarly jungles like this director yes
so this is by convention flask will
tells you to set up a templates
directory and static directory and it's
pulling from it automatically so for
example in the index route
I have render template index dot HTML so
by convention flask knows to go get that
template from the templates directory
within my template right here I have a
URL for static I didn't show this
because it was just more details but for
example I want to load a static file
main the jas and it's within the static
directory so yeah there's a lot of which
one which one this one no this is just
jQuery nothing complicated
so for the prosperity if you don't at
the calling on in the West
basically over maybe you are running so
it's a rainy ologist I what we did
before that may be running that cord in
situ instant right now survive no need
to do all that just
aw has the other f3 no you said oh that
gateway thank you
so you're asking if you don't have the
Gateway no no sorry I don't understand
the question I think so okay so what we
just our tradition one into this that's
way again yeah so the main difference is
so with a regular server you have to
like set up the server install the apps
install a web server right so you have
to stole a novelty WSGI server engine
eggs with us GI or you WSGI or unicorn
or anything like that set up the event
system on your own you're like you're
just like process manager system day
supervisor something that keeps your app
running so there is like this whole
manual work what is happening here is
that
zabba is creating an api gateway which
knows that whenever someone hits these
URL right here but it's going to do is
it's going to send an event to Al and
then it's gonna return respond with
whatever that was so a AWS gateway is
also something you can use for legacy
systems to kind of set an API on top of
the legacy system it can be done too
I'll use a light because yeah yeah
exactly
this example that I've shown is like
leaning too much on the website you can
have a lamb that that doesn't have an
end point that is just I mean might have
an end point but its primary usage it's
not a website or an API it can be again
just responding to a notification doing
something and pointing to somewhere else
you know so it's completely hidden and
it doesn't have a visual representation
so everything is right here what I can
do is what's the easiest way to share
this if you can share that link on the
page which one I'm gonna post it with
with just PI data and you guys can look
for the hashtag and the link is gonna be
there these whole thing when you open it
huh you can fork it and you can work on
it or you can just browse it like an
HTML for example right here it's the
bouquet one we were doing so the first
notebook has the links to the repo and
the Zappa documentation and all that the
fourth one has all the notes about all
our services and things to check yes
questions
did you get just the same as my name
yeah
[Music]
what does it say
[Music]
so there is a really important step here
and something that I didn't mention
which is we can let me I created a new
account for this tutorial so I'll mix
our true service
[Music]
I want to see if I can looking here I
can't
there you go so once you create your AWS
account you need to go to EMI now II am
Emma is the ac21
and you will have access here to your
tokens credentials identity providers
where is it security credentials and you
will have to generate this access case
you can create multiple ones actually
Amazon is gonna ask you to delete their
root access and create individual users
with less permissions that is of course
recommend if you're doing something
production and then you're gonna it's
gonna give you an access key and a
secret key and then you have to put
those within your home directory dot a
WS / credentials when you create the key
it's actually gonna tell you if you want
to download the file so you can just
download that one and place it right
there
if something fails you always do Saba
tail and Saba status to check the status
of the applications just status if it's
deployed or not
what is scheduled it's gonna give you
all the scheduled ones the error rate
this all looks let me just work here we
can check deploy just you can just do
deploy if you have only one stage you
can do what has to be installed
I think it's using bottom so if you do
people install Zappa and it's correctly
installed I'm not sure but I think it's
using both so this is the the lambda
from the AWS V you try before using here
you can see the the like invocations how
much time it usually takes this is gonna
be directly related to the cost of it
errors etc so it's all there so we've we
think here maybe we can do a gateway
all the services
so this is the API gateway kind of
channel that's created or this setup
thing should setting this whole proxy
been pointing to the lambda right here
and here is the lambda you see left
other right sorry
and within s3 we also have the pockets
which are pushing the application as I
told you before you can always publish
new version so you can go back I don't
know how to it from the okay first
versions so you have multiple versions
right all the deployments you are doing
you can always go back and maybe export
the code if you need it etc this there
is also here you can it's been the
support of environment variables and
right here
you can select multiple runtimes and you
can use your own one using the layer so
this is what I told you or you can set
your Python 3.6 layer with I don't know
numpy and pens and all that stuff
yeah it's just like so do you miss the
summarize the system architecture would
get so but how long does a derelict good
jewelry silver like services right at
this room
yeah it's its yard you're kind of
confusing it's it's it's confusing
because there are multiple services
running the two most important ones is
there is a lambda that its packaging
your code and actually right here you
can export that little end and see the
code inside
you can also package it with SAP others
a command for that and the results on
API gateway configuration so whenever so
this is gonna give you the domain right
a/c is something where is it ACS
something so this gateway is the one
that it's exposing something to the
world in a them in AWS with the gateway
the event
so whenever the gateway is receiving a
connection it's gonna forward that or
it's gonna invoke an event right on the
lambda and the land that returns that
bucket the s3 is kind of lateral you
donate it that often in this case as
they the whole application is large it's
being stored on s3 we can also see here
and other services
so you will also see activity on cloud
watch there are multiple right here's
your more information about them they
have these x-ray service so there are
multiple services that are involved in
the whole lamda process
so that is it guys I'm gonna post the
link so you can play it on your own if
you want just again it's real easy to
get started something that I forget to
mention is we build as a demonstration
these service which just tries to kind
of analyze colors extractant just a
simple k-means with a cycle and it's
it's trucks like the dominant colors of
the picture and this'll all host it on
AWS lander so it was just if you see the
code right here it's just a regular
flask up and you have your sample
settings and that is it this way we set
the certificate I'm sorry the custom
domain name because this one has our own
domain name and a certificate the
certificate is provided by Amazon Amazon
has its own product to provide SSL
certificate so another product more
you're adding to these big mixture of
products so if you want to check it out
also open source
if I can what to wear oh it's it's
already there it should be there Oh
[Music]
because yeah good one because there are
multiple branches for each one of the
steps we follow so master is empty and
then step four is the one that had the
scale of one for what no zap eyes just
orchestrating the Ale of a US service
yeah
container management is just another
product by itself Zappa doesn't work
with other cloud providers sadly but you
could export it again usually the app in
that it's a lambda it's not the platform
dependent but usually you're using all
their services that lock you in
so migrating a lambda means migrating so
you're using f3 you have to migrate to
the f3 equivalent of all etc you have to
migrate multiple services